the man who led the Boston Police during
the marathon bombing calls the Las Vegas
attack here Lawson law enforcement worst
fear realized former Police Commissioner
Ed Davis told CBS radio station WBZ to
stop something like this from a high
vantage point it's very difficult to do
Anna Warner is at the Four Seasons Hotel
here in Las Vegas which is actually
attached to the Mandalay Bay with a look
at the challenge of preventing such an
attack and a good morning good morning
we're on the 37th floor and we can see
where the gunman was he was five floors
down on that opposite corner of the
hotel the question is how do you stop a
gunman who is using the high floor of a
hotel like this to his advantage one of
the fundamental principles within
security is that you really cannot
protect against everything John Cho
helped to revamp security for the Wynn
and encore hotels in Vegas
he says security teams are always
looking out for anything suspicious but
Steven paddock didn't appear to raise
alarms in this case do you think that
this guy checked any of the boxes that
you would really be looking for I think
that that is probably one of the most
confounding aspects for the information
that's available right now is that he
doesn't seem to check check the boxes it
he does not seem to check the boxes I
don't know how it could have been
prevented Clark County Sheriff Joseph
Lombardo says investigators will now
comb through many hours of hotel
surveillance footage looking for clues
from the time Steven paddock checked in
last Thursday to when he broke windows
in two different rooms and began firing
we have determined that there has been
employees going to and fro from his room
and nothing nefarious was noticed I
think that he would have alluded
attention anywhere Steven Adelman is
with the event Safety Alliance he says
the only sure way to detect the weapons
coming into a hotel like Mandalay Bay
would involve impractical layers of
airport style security there is no hotel
in the u.s. that has that kind of x-rays
or metal detectors at every entrance in
every elevator because this is
literally unprecedented Mandalay Bay did
not comment Cho tells us that some
hotels do have baggage screeners that
visitors never see but as for protecting
the crowd down below even a trained
sniper aiming this direction would have
had problems because he would have been
aiming at innocent civilians as well as
the gunman Nora scary to think about
that Anna thank you so much